après
regardez en juin dernier la France a été
secouée par une vague d'émeutes après la
mort du jeune Naël tué par le tir d'un
policier et alors qu'une cagnotte avait
été créée pour soutenir la famille de
l'adolescent Jean Messia avait décidé
d'en fonder une autre qui a récolté 1,6
million d'euros j'ai pris l'initiative
de lancer une cagnotte pour la famille
du policier surnommé la cagnotte de la
honte elle avait rapidement suscité
l'indignation de certaines personnes et
c'est une provocation c'est scandaleux
et après une plainte déposée par la
famille de Naël contre Jean Messia pour
escroqurer en bande organisée l'homme a
été convoqué aujourd'hui par la police
alors Jean Messie a entendu pour
escroquerie après la cagnotte pour la
famille du policier auteur du tir mortel
sur Naël êtes-vous choqué par cette
cagnotte on n pas choqué non merci Jean
Messia d'être avec nous qui est choqué
par cette cagnotte oui non non non oui
oui non oui non oUI NON NON oui Jean
Messia vous êtes président du cercle de
réflexion vive français tout à fait
centre de réflexion je euh est-ce que on
va revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui parce que je sais que tout
le monde voulait vous venz tout le monde
vous invité ce soir merci je le sais je
le sais merci vous êtes des amours non
mais non mais non mais pas
nous inv tout le monde vous
voulez de votre vous avez ét entendu
aujourd'hui des centaines de potes ça
fait chaud au cœur hein non vousê vous
êtes vous êes vous avez été entendu
aujourd'hui j'été entendu ouais par la
police oui alors il va prendre 20 piges
pas du tout attendez on va en parler
dans un instant est-ce tu as bien mangé
en prison tu as maigri j'ai maigri monel
tu vas parvenir
la vérité la vérité c'est lui qui sort
d'auto là avec sa barbe ça y est alors
lui aussi
tu srieux on va pas les vannes là c'est
bon plus les vannes elles sont pas ouf
les gars vous comprenez cette plainte
contre votre cagnotte ou pas ben en fait
je l'ai jamais comprise et je l'ai
encore moins comprise aujourd'hui
puisque l'avantage quand vous vous
rendez à une audition libre c'est que on
vous
montre le contenu des plaintes qui sont
déposées contre vous et notamment les
éléments mat qui viennent fonder ces
plaintes or les dossiers sont vides
c'est exactement comme si je disais à
Bernard Montiel qu'il avait tué son
voisin et que le parquet convoquait
Bernard Montiel juste sur mes
déclarations parce que j'ai dit qu'il
avait tué son voisin donc moi j'ai pris
j'ai eu les dossiers entre les mains là
ce soir Bernard Monti n'a jamais tué
personne voilà mais mais c'est pareil
mais c'est comme moi moi je n'ai jamais
escroqué personne c'est c'est c'est
votre conclusion est la bonne donc moi
quand j'ai vu si vous voulez qu'il n'y
avait rien que c'était que du déclaratif
vous a dit quoi aujourd'hui ils vous ont
dit quoi alors bah il vous arrivez vous
arrivez donc là vous êtes entendu par
combien de je suis entendu par par un
policier ouais un policier j'étais avec
mes deux avocats donc maître Frédéric
Pichon et maître Gérald
pendelon euh et donc ça a duré 2h et
demi à peu près ouais et j'ai répondu à
toutes les questions qui c'est quoi les
questions c'est quoi bah les questions
c'est voilà quand est-ce que pourquoi
vous avez monté cette cagnotte est-ce
que vous avez été en contact au
préalable avec la famille du policier ou
avec ses collègues
voilà c'est c'est des des questions qui
qui visent à à éclairer en fait pour
vous avez monté cette cagnotte bah parce
qu'en fait j'ai trouvé ça absolument un
vraisemblable que un policier qui est
impliqué dans une affaire dont personne
au moment où on en parlait à l'époque
était connaissait les tenants et les
aboutissants on jette en quelque sorte
l'alali sur ce policier puisque quand au
plus haut niveau de l'État Emmanuel
Macron quelques heures à peine après cet
événement dit que le geste du policier
est inexcusable au mépris de
l'indépendance des pouvoirs parce que
c'est pas un président de la République
dans une démocratie moderne de juger si
un geste est inexcusable ou pas ça c'est
le pouvoir judiciaire qui doit qui doit
en juger donc j'ai pas compris pourquoi
tout le système médiatico-politique se
jetait je faisais un Arau sur le
policier sans considération pour sa
présomption d'innocence sans
considération pour la famille qu'il y a
derrière je rappelle quand même que ce
policier a été une fois qu'il a été en
prison préventive a été empêché pendant
un mois et demi de de d'avoir la visite
de sa femme et de son enfant en basâge
ce qui est du jamais vu dans une telle
affaire même les membres du Grand
bandettisme en 48h ils ont ils peuvent
voir leur famille au parloir là non
alors Gill Verdez vous euh on va on va
parler donc a jeanb vous vous êtes vous
trouvez êtes choqué par cette cagnotte
mais juste alors donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
vous ont dit au bout de 2h de bah au
bout de 2h3 forcé de constater que il
n'y a rien dans le dossier puisque la
vérité c'est que on na jamais vu
d'escroqueries sans escroc et d'escroc
sans escroquerie si vous voulez j'ai
excroqué personne la bande organisée B
ils ne l'ont pas démontré alors pire ils
m'ont dit enfin l'accusation de de
l'avocat de la famille c'est que
j'aurais utilisé des données de fichiers
confidentiels auquels j'aurais eu accès
de manière illégale sauf que l'enquête
faite par les policiers montre que
toutes les informations que j'ai diffusé
sur mes réseaux sociaux en réalité elles
étaient elles étaient déjà disponibles
plusieurs heures sinon plus plusur J on
y est là on du dossier donc donc donc en
fait ça tombe voilà il y a pas de y a
pas d'utilisation mais peu importe
qu'elle soit disponible peu importe
qu'elle soit disponible bah si non
laisse parler les grands non mais
pour jacqu d'abord pourquoi pourquoi
c'est non mais je connais l'argument
l'argument il nous l'a déjà sorti
l'année dernière selon lequel la semaine
dernière pardon selon lequel toutes les
le fait que les informations ne soient
pas publiques sousentendrait que vous
étiez de mèche et que vous publque c'est
ça le problème et et c'est bien ce que
j'allais dire c'est que toutes les
informations éaient déjà publique donc
il y a rien il y a rien à démontrer dans
cette affaire mais moi pour répondre
directement à cette question non je suis
pas choqué je suis pas choqué parce que
il s'agit de deux choses différent c'est
pas la peine il y a il y a il y a une
procédure judiciaire qui est en cours
c'est très rare de voir un policier dans
un cas comme celui-là être mis en
préventif pendant 4 mois et demi et de
toute façon cette cagnotte et il y a une
cagnotte qui est lancée vous l'avez
lancé pour le policier
est la
fam non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est totalement décoré de l'action
judiciire donc je ne vois pas en quoi ce
serait choquant la seule chose c'est que
personne n'est DUP du fait que vous
l'avez fait aussi pour des raisons je
dirais politiques et bien s
que juste
làdessus la récupération politique ou
l'inrument politique c'est on récupère
quelque chose qui existe déjà là je n'ai
rien récupéré puisque rien n'existait en
fait ce sont les 85000 donateurs qui en
ont fait un élément politique vous
comprenez dire la cagot attendez si la
cagnotte avait plafonné à 2 ou 3000 €
est-ce qu'on aurait fait cette émission
ce soir est-ce qu'il y aurait tous ces
problèmes non est-ce qu'il
faut si vous êtes poursuivi c'est aussi
parce qu'il y a quelque chose d'ammoral
de le faire au moment où vous l'avez
fait alors vous êtes en train de me dire
que dans une démocratie moderne quand on
est choqué par quelque chose on peut
finir en prison
moi moi je vous dis d'abord que je ne
suis pas choqué par cette cette
cagotte j'essaie d'interpréter le le le
la réaction et je pense que la famille
de du jeune Naël et tous ceux qui sont
entre guillemets face à vous vous
reprochent une faute morale une faute
politique d'avoir essayer
d'instrumentaliser cet événement de
voilà ça je ça je comprends tout à fait
je comprends tout à fait ça moi-même je
suis choqué par plein d'autres choses en
face mais être choqué par quelque chose
ne sign pas que c'est quelque chose de
criminalisable de
criminalis TR TR je pas les traduire en
justice et j'allais vous dire que ce
weekend la manifestation où il y avait
que 500 personnes à nanter en soutien à
la famille de naë c'est la même chose
aussi c'est une action politique voilà
oui monsieur oui vous êtes moi je suis g
je intervenir parce que Jean M déroule
son tapis rouge après son audition mais
c'est scandaleux son argumentaire vous
expliquer pourquoi il dit les données
étai publiques d'accord on lui reproche
d'avoir fait passer naë pour un
multirécidiviste en prenant des
informations confidentielles et en les
diffusant et jean- Messie a dit les
informations étaient publiques mais
Cyril on s'en fout totalement que ce
soit privé ou publique si c'est public
et qu'il utilise ces informations ça
s'appelle du recel et d'ailleurs bah si
c'est du recessel bah évidemment j'en a
mais pas du tout vous avez ét entendu
pour ça vous m'avez attend ét entendu ça
je peux vous répondre à cet élément
peine de commencer mais si vous voulez
répondez point par point point par point
vous me reprochez ça vous l'avez vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez dit la dernière
fois vous je peux répondre ou pas rel
réponds je laiss répondre je vous dis
simplement que que cet argument à la
noix vous l'avez déjà utilisé la
dernière fois qui est complètement
fallacieux la première chose vous AZ dit
au policiers de la brigade financière
que c'était à la noix un argument à no
oui oui parce que c'est pas c'est pas
les policiers qui disent ça c'est c'est
la partie adverse qui dit ça et la
partie adverse elle ne dit que des l'UR
qui sont pas PRV d'ord dire desairescom
fin la cagnotte rigis Mo
[Musique]
là je t' pas autorisé à me tutoyer so
d'accord on y vient alors vous l'
comment Soleiman la cagnotte lorsqu'elle
a été lancée la cagnotte lorsqu'elle a
été
lancée de le prononcer on ne fait pas on
ne fait pas référence dans la cagnotte à
naë la cagnotte n'a pas été fait contre
naë contre contre sa famille la cagnotte
a été lancée pour soutenir la famille du
policier il y a pas de mention à Naël ou
à sa famille dans la cagnotte donc tout
ça c'est du n'importe quoi vous mélangez
des choses qui ne sont pas mélangeables
le parcours comment dirais-je de petit
voyou qui était celui de naë avant sa
fin tragique ça n'a rien à voir avec la
lati au donateur Jean vous avez menti au
donateurs c'est ça qu'on vous reproche
pourquoi les donateurs pas là vous par
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a Daniel mais là
pourquoi les
dons il
RA pourquoi les donateurs n'ont pas
porté plainte la question répond à cette
question
on' votum quelqu'un si j'ai menti à
quelqu'un pourquoi il a pas porté
plainte contre moi si s'est senti
escroquer les donateurs ils ont pas
donné procuration à à la famille de Na
pour porter plainte contre moi vous
vivez dans quel état alors oui mamie non
j'ai juste dit pourquoi mentis par il il
a
just excuse-moi c'était très factuel il
était connu pour 15 fait il Ava pas été
mis jamais mis en examen mais voilà donc
il il a jamais connu pour fait de quoi
il a piqué les données du traitement des
antécédents j
dis ah je m'arrange oui oui ou faire
n'importe quoi
faire
vous avez utilisé les
donnéesamation c'est pas moi qui vais
payer le fris
d'avoc je te dis tu te démeras tout seul
qu'est-ce qui a dit FEM mais c'est vrai
vous êtes merveilleux et bravo pour tout
bravo
bravo touours dit pouri
iltii j'ai menti ou en quoi j'ai menti
toujours pas dit he oui
pardon avez expliqué au donateurs que
naë était un autre garçon que ce qu'il
était en réalité les les les donateurs
onont pas eu besoin de moi en
l'occurrence pour se faire une idée du
pédigré de Naël arrête de dire des
bêtises vous qui avez lancé la cagnotte
une première plateforme l'a refusé la
deuxè l'AC la cagnotte est venue
quelques jours après la mort de naë les
gens étaient déjà arché au courant de
qui il était arrêtez avec ça Messia il y
a pas mal de gens qui réagissent qui
disent que vous avez été euh vous dites
avoir été auditionné en édition libre et
vous dites que votre avocat l'avocat de
la partie adverse était présent non non
son avocat non non mes avocat ord très
bien ouais et pas pas donc vous étiez en
audition les voilà bah oui parce qu'il y
a en fait dans le dossier il y a rien
qui permette de détaer quoi que ce so ça
être entendu à nouveau ou bien fini
terminé non je pense que çaf je je peux
pas préjuger de ce qui va advevenir mais
enfin en tout cas le dossier est
totalement vide c'est un procès
politique c'est pas un procès juridique
puisqu'il n'y a aucun élément de fait ou
de droit susceptible de justifier une
poursuite de la procédure depuis le
début d'ailleurs si le parquet a ouvert
une enqu a accepté en 48 heur d'ouvrir
cette enquête c'est tout simplement pour
des raisons politiques pour calmer les
émeutes qui est au demorant même un
échec puisque les émeutes ont quand même
lie mais vous êtes conscient que c'était
peut-être pas très àroit de le faire au
moment où vous l'avez fait c'était quand
même c'est surtout ça quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de faute morale c'est
quand même quelque chose qui était très
choquant à ce momentl on était tous pe
sous choc quand même c'est une faute
morale de soutenir la famille d'un
Polier moi j'avais une question
généralement quand il y a une famille
qui est endeuillée qui qui s qui a perdu
quelqu'un là on crée une cagnotte ça je
suis d'accord moi ma question elle est
factuelle elle est simple elle est
innocente c'est que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on crée une cagnotte pour ce
monsieur là je parle pas des faits je
parle pas des faits même pour sa famille
Mme pour sa
famille je comprends pourquoi on crée
une cagnotte quand c'est pour payer les
f d'avocat et Cera mais pourquoi jus 1
million SAV pas il SAV pas ça prend tu
la coupe la cagnotte ça se coupe une
cagnotte je vais vous
répondrelionme je je vais vous répondre
dans la tête des gens ça sonne comme une
récompense quand même et c'est un peu
délicat oui je vous entends mais je vais
vous répondre lorsque le policier
lorsque lorsque le policier a été
lorsque le policier a été immédiatement
embastillé en en prison préventive et
que l'adresse de sa femme et de son
petit enfant ont été dénoncé sur les
réseaux sociaux une première fois puis
une deuxième le traitement c'estàdire le
salaire du policier a été interrompu
donc on a derrière cette affaire une
famille qui était aussi dans la
tourmente et je vois pas au nom de quoi
on serait interdit de ne pas avoir de
compassion pour la famille d'un policier
et au nom de quoi notre seule compassion
doit aller vers la famille vers la
famille d'un petit voyou excusez-moi
est-ce est-ce que la question que tout
le monde se pose est-ce que c'était pour
créer un buzz aussi cette canot c'était
pas pour créer un buzz attendez mais
encore une fois est-ce que moi je suis
maître de ce que de de de de ce que de
de ce que la cagnotte est devenue si si
la cagnotte avait avait avait plafonné à
1000 ou 2000 € C
personne n'en aurait parlé c'est pas moi
oui c'est pas moi qui c'est pas moi moi
j'ai lancé un appel mais on aurait pu
avoir 2000 7000 8000 je sais pas qui
aurait imaginé qu'on aurait près de
100000 donateurs c'est c'est en cela que
ça devient politique c'est-à-dire que ce
que j'ai ressenti moi j'étais pas le
seul à le ressentir et que derrière cet
appel il y a un record historique de
personnes qui ont participé parce que
derrière les émeutes ont scandalisé les
Français or les Français on IB ne
pouvant pas exprimer leur colère
vis-à-vis de la chianlie qui est
installée par certaines immigrations
tous les jours dans dans nos rues et
bien ils se sont emparés de cette
cagnotte comme d'un ils on ont fait un
objet politique pour dire leur ralbol et
pour exprimer quelque chose il faut
entendre ce qui ce que dit cette
cagnotte pas seulement la critiquer donc
vous comprenez les émeutes alors ben non
justement quel fois vous avez dit non
pas choquer vous j'ai non parce que
c'est pas choquant qu'il ait fait ça
maintenant c'est vrai que la somme qui
est
astronomique ch à ce niveau-là c'est
vrai comme il dit S avait été moins on
en aurait pas parlé ce que je regarde
c'est que c'est politisé et que c'est
surfé un peu sur la la souffrance par
exemple il faut pas oublier ce jeune
garçon qui a été tué quand même
évidemment la famille du policier aussi
évidemment les menaces de mort qu'il a
reçu évidemment la vie brisée évidemment
pas d'argent on sait ce que gagnent les
policiers après tout il avait le droit
de le faire attention il a continué à
toucher son salaire he le policier non
non ça été interu moment un moment la
canot était lancée le SAL non mais après
il a remis géralmanin l'a remis son
salaire oui mais ça au début on savait
pas au début on savait pas alors oui je
peux vous donner une information si vous
voulez neutre sur la cagnote oui alors
je vous entends très mal monsieur oui je
peux vous donner une information neutre
si vous voulez sur la cagnote des 1
million et Jean mas si je me trompe vous
pourvez me corriger des
1630 an vousi non des
1636000 32000 d'accord on retire les
droits de donation et droit de mutation
60 % soit 938000 mais ce que je dis est
notutre c'est pas polémique jeis vous
corriger c'est faux et on re ce que
prend la plateforme c'estàdire 68000
donc je pense que la famille va toucher
625000 € après impôt et taxes c'est faux
je crois vous avez pas très bien
travailler votre dossier parce qu' la
fiscalité des donations elle se fait sur
les dons de plus de 500 € or nous avons
à peu près 90 % des dons qui sont
inférieurs à 500 € donc non taxa non la
totalité ils vont toucher la totalité
vous êtes sû de çael BR il vont payer
quelques brottis sur tous les dons qui
sont supérieurs à 500 € mais mais comme
la quasi majorité en la totalité des
dons est inférieure à 500 € sont ils
sont pas taxables c'est la loi fiscale
vous avez 85000 donateurs 85000
donateurs mais pour pour un don moyen de
20 ou 30 € donc ça sera pas taxé et seul
les les montants supérieurs à 500 €
parce que ce que votre raisonnement e
été vrai si on avait une personne
physique ou morale qui avait donné cette
somme donc là effectivement ça aurait
été le don d'une personne identifiée et
donc taxable à 60 % là c'est pas le cas
il y a 85000 personnes avec un don moyen
de 20 ou 30 € donc taxer bah non toucher
làus pensez pas qu'il vont vous donner
un petit truc le le le d'abord l'argent
ne transite pas par un tiers quand on
ouvre une cagnotte c'est au nom d'un
bénéficiaire don il faut est-ce que la
famille va peut-être vous donner quelque
chose mais non mais j'en veux pas moi
j'ai pas fait ça pour ça rien ou ah non
non il a pas le droit ou ah non non là
c'est absolument impossible il aura rien
il n a jamais été il n a jamais été
question ah oui enessous de table ouais
pe a jamais été question mais alors ça
c'est diffamatoire a je
plaisanteamation j'espère que vous êtes
bien payé ici hein
Atta il a aucun problème j'ai aucun
problème avec ça oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe et la et la famille donc ne peut
pas utiliser ça pour l'action en justice
on est bien d'accord c'est uniquement
famille non il faut bosser vos dossiers
uniquement pour les dépenses familiales
famille peut utiliser l'argent pour
payer ses avocats par exemple mais par
contre si il y a une condamnation
pécuniaire la famille ne peut pas
utiliser l'argent pour payer une
condamnation pécuniaire mais les frais
de justice entendu comme des frais
d'avocat là ils peuvent je les entendais
comme pénalité éventuelle donc on est
d'accord pour une fois bien enseigné
quand même vous êtes dit à mon avis IGN
attendez j'ai j'ai pas fait que des
études dans ma vie mais j'en ai fait
quelquesunes me permettant de répondre à
vos questions vous avez fait quoi ben
j'ai fait 12 années d'études après le
bac non quoi j'ai un doctorat en
sciences économiques je suis encien
élève de Sciences pour Paris ancien élèv
de Lena vous êtes beaucoup ancien élèves
pardon non vous avez fait les deux Lena
et S pour Paris ouais vous avez arrêté
vous avez juste rentré et sorti ou non
non non j'ai fait 3 années d'études à
Science Po 2 années à Lena et 9 années
d'études pour mon doctorat pour passer
jour sur et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
C8 il m'attaque il
m'ta c'est pas à toi je répondre ça me
ça me permet de corriger les quelques
imprécisions et quelques ignorances et
de combler quelques lacunes sur ce
plateau c'est vrai
pas de non mais parlez pas de moi non
non non pas du tout je pas non j'ai eu
peur merci par contre luiut y aller
l'attaquer attaz problme avec ça qui
veut réagir moi sur la je suis un peu
choqué sur la cagnotte parce que ok il
est parti 4 mois en prison et je rejoins
ce que dit on aurait pu la la la bloquer
à 10000 € indemniser son salaire aller
jusqu'à 1lion6 bon il est parti en
prison peut-être il y en a qui dis
fallait pas qu'il y aille fallait qu'il
aille mais 1lion 6 la famille va faire
quoi avec les 1lion question que je vous
pose moi cour ils vont aller au
restaurant ils vont aller acheter une
maison ils vont acheter une voiture sur
la mort d'un petit il vont être contents
de dépenser cet argent moralement ils
vont se dire on a pris 100 million 6
parce que notre mari ou notre père ou
notre oncle à tirer à bout port sur un
gamin mais on va aller quand même au
Maldive avec
l'argent parce que vous Croz non mais
attendez vous viz dans quel monde vous
croyez que vous croyez que quand un flic
tire sur quelqu'un avec cette issue
tragique qu'on a connu vous croyez que
le flic il dort tranquille en disant
j'ai fait j'ai explosé quelqu'un
j'ai tiré sur quelqu'un je suis
content un policier il faut savoir qu'en
France un policier qui sort son arme
dans de telles conditions sa carrière
est foutue il il la ressortira plus
jamais d'accord bon donc ça veut dire
que sa carrière dans la police est
terminée quel que soit l'issue he sa
carrière dans la police est terminée et
donc il va falloir qu'il se
reconvertisse bah oui enfin écoutez le
petit enfin on va pas revenir voilà
c'est pas un petit par trop t alors il
mérite pas cette il mérite pas cela je
dis pas ça je dis mais ce qui tue en
France c'est pas la police c'est les
refus d'obtempéré si vous vous arrêtez
vous risquez rien voilà c'est tout il
faut le dire et le répéter quand la
police vous intime lors de vous arrêter
il faut vous arrêter si vous ne vous
arrêtez pas vous mettez le doigt dans un
engrenage qui peut effectivement être
tragique c'est tout c'est malheureux il
y a des choses à pas dire quand même
c'est trop là c'estàdire c'est trop non
c'est la vérité attendez mais vous dans
quel pays dans quel pays au monde quand
quand quelqu'un fonce sur un un barrage
de police la ne sort pas son pour tirer
il barage il a failli attendez vous avez
vu les dernières vidéos vous avez vu les
der
vid il a fail écraser un cycliste des
piéons
et je te l'ai dit la semaine dernière il
avait écrasé ton ton gamin tu aurais dit
quoiou oui bonsoir Monsieur Messia moi
j'ai l'intime conviction que vous n'êtes
pas un escrot et que c'est pas un réseau
en non pas du tout je vous dis
effectivement que j'ai voté il a pris ch
avec son P à mon
av non je trouve que vous avez fait
quand même passer naë P à son âme pour
le délinquant qu'il n'est pas parce que
la seule sanction qu'il a même si il
était connu des services de police
c'était une sanction éducative en 2022
c'est bien ça problème non mais
justement je vous dis donc soutenir les
les policiers absolument oui il y a
aucun souci mais au dépend de la mort et
de se faire de cet argent de la mort de
ce petit non je suis pas d'accord et la
différence et si vous me permettez la
différence entre vous et Naël P son âme
c'est que vous vous avez un casi
judiciaire qui entachche aussi pas bien
évidemment bien si si si si
siamème vous avez été aussi condamné AZ
aussi condamn pascrit révis alors vous
aussi vous
AZ ça sert à faire doctorat s économi
parce que ce que vous ditespend des
condamnations ça dépend des catégories
de condamnation certaines ne sont
pas alors moi vous avez le droit en fait
vous avez le droit si vous de faire une
cagnotte vous avez le droit moi je je ça
me gêne au niveau de l'éthique au niveau
de la moral c'estàd que je trouve qu'il
y a un truc un peu un peu obsène un peu
indécent parce que j'ai l'impression que
malgré vous même si vous avez
instrumentalisé ce fait divhivers il y a
un truc un peu de Battle en gros combien
elle a eu la cagnotte de la mère de Naël
et combien il a eu la cagnotte du du du
policier et que donc du coup comme elle
elle a eu 490000 et que lui il a eu plus
d'un million en gros on se dit ah ouais
donc le pays est vra complètement
fracturé voilà et moi je suis du côté de
la police et je je je je soutiens ce
policier mais cette instrumentalisation
financière et pécunière moi elle me
déplais je la trouve Obs parce que je
trouve qu'elle divise encore plus que
avant le j'entends ce que vous me dites
mais je vais vous poser une question
est-ce que vous avez pas été choqué par
l'instrumentalisation de la mort de naë
par des grandes stars qui l'ont traité
immédiatement DEP ans parti trop tô été
la première à le dire sur le de la même
manière mais là l'argent c'est un truc
c'est un truc vraiment fort je quand
vous plaquez le montant quand même à la
guule de de de de la maman de naë je je
je comprends que ce soitès très violent
pour je comprends bien mais moi vous sa
moi je excusez-moi mais personne
n'aurait pu prophétiser que la cagnote
allait faire autant avec autant de
donateurs vous savez quoi je vais même
vous dire quelque chose quand la cagnote
a été fermé j'ai reçu mais des tombau de
messages de gens qui me disent mais
pourquoi elle a été fermée on voulait on
voulait participer j'ai même reçu des
des des personnes qui m'ont envoyé des
chèqus intitulés monsieur le policier ou
monsieur F des ambition politiqu
monsieur mess si vous AZ des ambition
politiques en faisant ça vous fracturez
encore plus tout sur cette affaire là la
seule ambition que j'ai eu c'était
d'aider une famille que ça été mal pris
par la famille d'en face ça par par
contre ça pose un problème si la PR
c'est qu'ils onté ple contre moi ou mais
il y a plein de gens qui sont moi je
suis pas avec la famille d'en face PE
importeelle est un
peé géraline maill je vous dire un truc
moi je comprends tout à fait que il y a
des choses qui peuvent qui puissent
choquer je suis moi-même
choqué France voilà mais c'est pas pour
ça que j'iraai pter plainte pour quelque
chose qui me choque vous savez en en la
démocratie si on doit définir une la
démocratie c'est le droit à choquer mais
quand il y avait la cagnotte quand il y
avait la cagnotte du boxeur détingé je
sais pas si vous en souvenez pendant
diff oui mais alors pourquoi c'était
différent la différent parce que la
cagnotte a été ouverte pour payer
justement la condamnation pécunite
interrompue donc il a pas le droit non
non non non non non non soyez précis la
cagnotte la cagnotte a été interrompue
parce que elle a été ouverte pour aider
ce boxeur à payer une condamnation
financière or ça c'est interdit par la
loi c'est illégal c'est sur cette base
juridique que la cagnote a été fermée la
cagnotte que moi j'ai lancé pour la
famille du policier elle n'a pas pu être
interdite par la loi parce qu'elle n'est
pas illégale et Dieu sait et Dieu sait
qu'il y a eu des saisines du procureur
AR et tout ce qui n'est pas interdit par
la loi est permis alors ça peut choquer
je comprends mais depuis quand quand on
est ch ché on finit dans un dans une
audition
libre vous êtes d'accord si on fait une
cagnotte par exemple pour nordal
Lelandais ou pour la maman de
jonathanra question
question ser mais je serais extrêmement
choqué mais je pourquoi je je porterai
plinte ça serait choquant si c'est pas
illégal dans une démocratie comme la
France tout ce qui n'est pas interdit
permis ça sera fait oui non à 81 % 81 %
au revoir merci on se retrouve dans un
instant merci Jean m merci merci